at the height of Paris Hilton's Powers  Hollywood greenlit a film called the  hottie and the Naughty by the time the  movie had been filmed and dumped into  theaters it was already a punch line it  might just be one of the worst films of  all time Hilton plays a hottie who  refuses to date and tell her naughty  friend also finds somebody in theory the  film was a comedy But ultimately its  parade of mean-spirited characters gross  out nonsense and offensive plot points  yielded negative laughs Richard Roper  was particularly scathing in his  assessment of the actors saying nobody  in this movie should really have a  career in movies Joel David Moore who  played the film's male lead Nate Cooper  won the Razzy award for worst on-screen  couple along with Hilton he must be  grateful that James Cameron didn't feel  like Roper did about his acting  abilities casting him as Dr Norm  Spellman and Avatar